il y a un maniaque qui cherche à nous mettre fin à tous
nous devons faire quelque chose
je rassemble la plus grande équipe
jamais appelée c'est mon meilleur ami oui
valkyrie nous devons nous battre à nouveau
les gardiens me donnent ça et jane l'
ancienne ex-petite amie judy favoriser jane
favoriser
vous n'êtes pas comme les autres dieux de tuer
thor aimer le tonnerre plein d'esprit pg-13 billets
en vente maintenant
comment ça va les gars
nous sommes tous sur le point de mourir vous avez dit que ce
serait des vacances relaxantes
j'ai dit que ça allait être comme un moment de
détente  des
moments de vacances comme celui-ci nous devons nous réunir
toute une réunion hein
quel film d'aventure classique de thor d'
accord nous devrions y aller
thor amour et tonnerre billets en vente
lundi
vous